nfl owners met virtually on
tuesday they've been meeting virtually
throughout the pandemic not all the time
but they do their meetings that way and
this is a
a a separate and special one from the
normal quarterly get-togethers and they
had a couple of items of business they
wanted to take care of
one a contingency plan that we've been
discussing and we've added to some of
the reporting at first we just kind of
dropped out there hey if they lose games
they're going to play
a 16-team playoff field well the way
it's going to work is
ideally 17 seasons or 17 weeks
17 seasons 17 weeks 256 games get them
all in
stick with the current playoff format of
14 teams
if you can't get all the games in 17
weeks you have your 18th week
if you have any and what they're saying
is meaningful games that can't be
played with that 18th week yeah then
that's when
you expand the playoffs from 14 to 16.
now meaningful i assume
if it would have any impact whatsoever
on playoff seeding now you could say
well it's only meaningful if it impacts
who gets in or who doesn't get in
or who gets to buy everything else two
three four five
six that's not meaningful i i think they
should strive to get every game played
yes and and and uh and now now if you
if you play a game between the jaguars
and uh the bengals and both are
mathematically eliminated and there's no
way that
that the outcome of that game can affect
any tiebreakers or seating then i guess
you go ahead and up and and stick with
14.
but you know i just think they should
try to get every game played period
and then and then uh if if any games
aren't played then you make a good faith
fair assessment of whether or not you
should expand the playoffs
to 16. if it has any impact whatsoever
though i think you should yeah i mean i
i would think so too right mike that
would be the first thing i
i at least thought of and and with that
scenario
you know okay well seating has to be a
part of that conversation
right i mean it has to be if there was a
big game between
you know just two top tier football
teams and
oh well let's just say we could go go to
the the afc let's say the steelers and
chiefs are tied same record right
uh and i know that's not gonna happen
because they're gonna play each other at
some point and that's gonna be a tie
breaker but you know what i mean
students and chiefs don't play each
other
oh yeah you're right they don't i don't
know what i was thinking i thought they
were so let's say they end up tying
right and let's say it comes down to
man it's going to come down to this tie
breaker that tiebreaker whatever it is
and it might be strength of schedule
something like that like i guess what
i'm saying is
how far down the line will they go as
far as
this has meaning for the impact of the
seating
or is it going to have like a have to
have a direct effect i guess is
i think you know any effect whatsoever
they need to get the game played they
need they need
and this is the way it's going to work
right now
the the actual language hasn't been
crafted yet
they've just approved going forward with
it but remember
if the meaningful game can't be played
then that's when you expand the
postseason
to 16 games i just think if the outcome
of that game would have any impact
whatsoever directly or indirectly on the
configuration of the playoff tree
and that game can't be played then you
flip the switch
and you go to 16. and look i think
they're going to air on the side chris
of going to 16 because if you lose
regular season games you are losing
money or and and there isn't
a direct bright line connection between
not televising these games and losing
money from the networks because it's
more complicated it's a broader
relationship they're currently
negotiating new deals but but still
for the nfl ideally you want to deliver
everything you've promised
yeah if you don't deliver regular season
games you can turn around and deliver
two extra
postseason games that would have value
so
i think that the nfl probably
is going to be inclined to implement
the 16 team contingency plan if in any
doubt whatsoever
let's go ahead if we've lost any gate
and the way it was told i lose
we're going to 16. right now this
meaningful thing has been thrown on top
of it and i don't think anybody really
knows what that means
no no i don't that's where i like you
know bring up to your like let's django
jaguars and bangles you know like i said
oh the game might not have any direct
meaning
as far as those two teams or anything
like that or anything to get in
get in but that's like that's what i'm
asking are they going to play that game
if it becomes down to oh a strength of
schedule or oh now this team won so this
team
becomes the one seed and this team
becomes the two seed you know
and i think here's here's the right way
to frame it yeah i think the goal is
going to be to try to play
every game in that 18th week if it gets
postponed but if they can't get the game
played i think this is where the
question comes in of expanding the
playoff field
if they can't get that jaguars bengals
game played
what impact does that have to have
on that's the duration of the playoff
tree in order to activate the 16 games
and
i i would say any whatsoever yeah
strength of victory strength of schedule
strength of this strength of that
and it doesn't take many tie breakers to
get into those because it seems like
every year now we're
not doing one of these crazy
calculations of
all the different permutations that
affect the ultimate seating
if it has any effect whatsoever and you
can't get the game played
go to 16 boom period that's it
now again they haven't crafted the
actual language and one of the
factors here and this is an example of a
situation where the nfl puts the cart in
front of the horse and gets the public
behind it
and then it pressures the union to agree
the union doesn't have to agree
the union will take the position that
this is a
subject of bargaining that they must
come to the union and say we would like
to do this let's talk about it
are you okay with it is there something
you would want in exchange for it and
it was five six years ago chris where
the nfl was careening toward expanding
the playoffs from 12 to 14.
what happened this year was going to
happen 2015
2016-ish yeah and the union said no no
no no i mean you may you may just assume
that we're fine with two extra playoff
games
and that we're fine with taking our cut
of the extra money that comes from it
you may assume that but you assume wrong
we still have a voice in this and they
never agreed to it until it was part of
the broader negotiation
back in february of this year that's
when the 14 team
playoff field was implemented so there
is no
no uh absolutely no
uh way that you can that you can just
assume
that the union is okay with it yeah they
may not be right now now my
understanding is
look if revenue is going to be lost yeah
as a result of not playing regular
season games and this is a way to make
it back
the nfl pa is going to be inclined to
agree but i think it would be a mistake
to just think the nfl is going to ram
this through with no concession
whatsoever to the union because this is
this is how bargaining works is
something the league wants
okay you want it what are you giving us
right what are you doing for us well you
benefit from it well maybe we do but we
don't have to agree to it so we have
some power here
what are you doing for us to get us to
agree to this
mike do you think they're gonna try to
look for a reason to expand the playoff
format
like okay it's you know two meaningless
games that need to be made up
all right and have very little
implications if l
if any at all right let's just say if
one team won
you know this team went from the seventh
seed to the sixth seed and the sixties
went to the seventh seed
all right where there's not really
difference there right they're still on
the road in the playoff game
is the nfl gonna use that and go well i
i don't like this we need to have an
extra team in the playoff because
they're gonna want the extra money in a
down year and things like that
that's the other thing that jumped off
to my head immediately in reading this
will they find and i don't want to say
this but lack for a better way of saying
it
an excuse to say 16 team play playoff
field this year
you know we had this one game and
everyone might go well that one game
meant nothing but they
just do it do you think that's a
possibility well i think that
look they get to what i was saying
earlier they're going to err on the side
of calling anything meaningful that they
possibly can so oh we lost one game
we got in 255 not 256. there was one
game that
even with the extra week we couldn't get
it played oh well here we go to 16. and
look meaningful it can be yeah
so broad defined narrowly and broadly i
mean look it's
every game is meaningful to the draft
standings yeah that's right
to the draft order if they care about
that now they they
you know they pay no attention to the
man behind the curtain teams have an
incentive to lose games that would they
really want to force in an extra game
just to determine whether or not the
loser gets a higher spot but who knows
maybe that one last game determines the
first overall pick in the draft is that
meaningful i just think that if they
can't get
any game in let's go ahead and activate
16 yeah and and uh and that's that
unless you can look at it and say
there's no way that it affects
anyone strategically for playoffs for
draft status for anything but it's all
to be determined it's all to be written
see they have to take this concept
and put it on paper that's the next step
so the cart
is in front of the horse and there are
some issues that need to be ironed out
and hopefully they get them ironed out
soon because week 10 is upon us
tomorrow night when the titans and the
colts get together
now there was at one point
a thought that a 16 team playoff field
would look like it did back
in 1982 when you were
to what two yes yeah during the sea yeah
you were born in august so you were
two in 82. i was not i was 17 which
is somewhat depressing considering i'm
sitting here talking to a two-year-old
now
which you know i guess is kind of
fitting based upon some of the things
you say
um as aunt jeannie could probably
confirm in
ways that uh we we can't mention on tv
given your
vocabulary which uh is uh very uh
colorful at times
so in 1982 when they lost
seven games per team to a strike they
just did a straight
one through eight no regard for
divisions
top to bottom playoff tree and there was
talk that that's what they would do
that you don't get dibs for being a
division winner you don't get one of the
top
seeds for being a division winner you
you don't get the automatic
four spot if you are the best of four
bad teams in the nfc east
they ended up deciding to go ahead and
let the division winners have home games
troy vincent the executive vp of
football operations with the nfl spoke
with peter king yesterday here's their
exchange on that point
there was a time that there was
consideration
for not giving the four division winners
they would make the playoffs but not
giving them the top four seeds is that
correct
that is correct and the thought was
there was
if any time you could maybe change up
some things
in the current environment why reward
a team that frankly
may win their division with five wins
why reward them with a
a home game against the team that might
win 10 or 11.
correct and that was frankly that was a
debate peter of the committee for quite
some time
yeah for quite some time eventually what
eventually turned the tide against it
i would just say when you think about
the team or the divisions that were
um tradition really the best way to
answer this tradition
and not moving away from tradition
in the year where we've had a lot of
uncertainty and if we didn't have to do
it why do it
is there any way that sanity can prevail
in the playoffs
and we can please not have uh
potentially a team with seven or eight
wins in a regular season a normal
regular season
not host a playoff game against the team
that might have even 11 or 12 wins
i think eventually we may get there i
think
what we're seeing which potentially
could occur and we still got a lot of
ball to play
but what potentially can occur i think
it lends to that discussion
troy's written for one of his former
teams the philadelphia eagles to win
some games so that isn't relevant but
look if we're going to get caught up in
tradition the tradition of the nfl
if you have eight teams per conference
in the playoffs is to not
give the division winners an automatic
home game it's to seed them from scratch
so
tradition is a malleable word in this
context and that's the tradition it's
only been done one other time but that's
the tradition
i look this gets into a different issue
that we have been griping about as the
nfc east has been horrible every year
there's a division that doesn't hold its
weight because there's only four teams
in the division
that's part of the reality of only
having four teams in the division and
yes it looks good on paper
to have the conferences separated in
four divisions and four teams it's
symmetrical it's neat it's tidy
it's geographically accurate for the
most part unlike the days when the
arizona cardinals were in the nfc east
which was just ridiculous but uh
there are flaws and that's the big flaw
um but
but so the bottom line is whoever
if they don't get all the games in is in
first place in the nfc east is going to
be the fourth seed
period unless one of those teams goes on
a tear
and ends up with a better record than
the packers or the saints
or the seahawks who are currently
leading the other three divisions and
you know the other side of this too
chris
we talked about this yesterday after
this weekend
every team will have played nine games
yeah minimum right some will have 10.
uh in 1982 it was just nine games i mean
we are at the top of the fifth the
complete game
is there uh the question is how many
more games will they get in and it's not
a ridiculous question even though the
nfl
currently has played all of its games as
we see number one
the pandemic continuing to spread record
numbers hundred thousand
new cases for six straight days maybe
seven now i've lost count of that
and we see more and more hot spots
popping up and it's
we're just used to it now oh somebody's
on the covet 19 reserve list
and then the next day you find out how
many guys get knocked out because of it
yesterday we'll be talking about this
coming up it's ben roethlisberger
knocked out because of it so uh and not
not because he has it
just because he sat next to vance
mcdonald on the plane back from dallas
that's enough to get him knocked out for
five days
so it just feels like at some point
they're gonna lose some games they're
gonna get some games postponed they may
not be able to make them up
but uh my point is this we're already
approaching the point where they can
feel like okay we did we got enough done
nine games we got nine that's enough
dump i mean they were talking about
reducing it to 12.
we're almost there no just a few weeks
away from getting to 12.
everything after that's gravy it is then
we the meat and potatoes are you i mean
you're right we've
we've made it through i think you know
not to say the tough part but
you know we've at least figured out how
to exist here
with covet 19 i know it might get worse
and whatever else but
it does seem that you know teams when
cases arise they're doing the right
things
for the most part they're following
protocols you know
the specific scenario with vance
mcdonald that's one i don't really get
in the nfl
right now with like you know the common
knowledge right now of yeah you could be
not feeling well and not test positive
for two or three days after that
you know to me that that's one that
needs to be remedied there or fixed a
little bit
i mean because they're lucky that you
know they get away
out of a plane flight a football game
that it doesn't become more of an
outbreak that way but it does seem like
coaches players for the most part still
are staying on the straight and narrow
have kept that message to their team
their players everything like
that and just uh i i don't i feel
confident
i do i'm not saying we get all 256
but i feel like we're gonna get very
close to to accomplishing the full
season and feeling good about it and
having
legit playoffs and everything like that
the problem is and it continues to be
when the players coaches and other
essential personnel go their separate
ways at the end of the day unless they
are in hermetically sealed rooms in
their homes
and they are exposed to no other human
beings you are going to have
the ever increasing possibility of
someone
bringing it to the facility and
you know shereen williams and i talked
about this last night on pftpm
all you have to do is watch a game no
one on the sidelines
is behaving as if anyone
else has it no they're behaving under
the presumption that no one else has it
that hey we're all tested every day
we're fine we're clear
and i don't know what it's going to take
to get the message across to those guys
just because you're tested every day
doesn't mean you don't have it
today vance mcdonald the latest example
of a guy
who was all clear testing negative
negative negative negative yeah gave a
sample sunday morning went and played
the game
all came back positive it can happen at
any time and
just watch how they and let's just set
aside
as we're all trying to do now this
ridiculous political argument that masks
don't work the nfl
requires the wearing of masks doctors
have proven that masks help
protect you and those around you look at
look at what's going on on the sidelines
you got so many guys that don't have
their noses covered which you may as
well definitely not the damn mask on
you've got guys in each other's faces
talking loudly
they're they're trying to win a football
game see that's where
you can't get hard right the two plates
balanced now we want to win a football
game
so this plate of maybe i'm going to get
exposed to this virus
that gets that gets forgotten definitely
front and
front and center is doing what you have
to do well and front and center to like
what you're saying is you know a lot of
these guys are going wait but
it's okay for me out there to be
smashing faces with somebody that's good
there but then when i get on the
sideline
i have to do this why just for a message
so i think that's where players
no no right but that's that's why that's
why people need to say
you're at greater risk of catching it
when you're face to face on the sideline
for five minutes for 10 minutes and then
you come back and you sit next to that
guy again after the next drive
it's that prolonged exposure the person
who has it right who is breathing that
into your face
the the the real quick tackle the guy
put him on the ground get up and go
that's not nearly enough
to get you exposed if that guy has it
and
i don't know if see you need to have
full buy-in from all the coaches and i
don't think there's full buy-in from all
the coaches no
i think coaches who think it's no big
deal and why are we worried about this
why are we wasting time on it
and they're not explaining it to their
guys the way they should and also
they're trying to explain to their guys
what they need to do with
that that's the biggest you only have so
many hours in the day you're right to
preach to your players you're going to
preach football not viruses
that that's that's really what it is you
know these aren't bad people
you know for the most part you you know
a lot of them i do they they want to be
good and and do the right thing and
they're not trying to endanger people
but it is their livelihoods and it's the
emotions of the game
and it's a pressure you know
pressure-packed job and everything like
that to where
yeah they want to and i'm sure when they
get home they hear it from their kids
and their wife hey we saw you without
your mask on i mean i've had a few
coaches say that that's what's really
kept them on the straight and narrow is
their family at home
going you look like an idiot you know
you know my mom called after the game
and texted me and said she saw me a few
times without it
you know that's checking but yes it's
the emotions it's you know the
i got to communicate this really fast
and really quick and you need to hear it
because i got to go back here and coach
or you need to run out in the field
and that's where yeah there's a little
disconnect let alone that we know
there's just not people in the league
as far as players coaches that really
fear it like we've always been saying
and that's where there is a little bit
of an issue there
and the league decided a couple of weeks
ago to strongly encourage distancing and
math squaring at all times on the
sidelines even if players are in the
game but they currently aren't
in the game and it's just hard to get
them to do it voluntarily at some point
it needs to be a mandate and the league
is concerned that that's an area where
the virus can spread
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports